dry erase boards are also known as white
boards the boards wipe perfectly clean
due to its non-porous surface and the
dry erase
ink dry erase ink contains release
agents which prevent the pigments from
permanently adhering to the
surface green and black dry erase boards
can also be used as chalk boards while
gray and low gloss white double as
projection
boards the surface material is a
porcelain coated steel sheet flexible
enough to be rolled up but also pressure
sensitive to start the roll is mounted
on a cutting
machine a technician programs the
machine to cut the roll to a specific
length based on the board's
Dimensions workers verify the length and
check that the piece is
square the surface material will be
applied to one of seven types of
substrate ranging from cardboard to
medium density fiberboard known as
MDF the next step is to cut the large
sheet of substrate in this case MDF into
board size pieces another technician
enters the length and width into the
cutting
machine once complete the machine ejects
the substrate which is now cut to the
the exact size of the
board next the substrate is put through
a hot glue machine the machine applies
polyurethane adhesive to what will be
the back of the dry erase
board as the substrate exits a sheet of
foil is applied to the glued
surface the foil prevents moisture from
entering which would warp the
substrate the board moves through two
steel rollers which flatten the foil and
press out any trapped
air next the surface material is applied
to the other side of the
substrate a craftswoman uses an air hose
to clear away any dust from the side of
the board once cleaned the board goes
through the glue
machine the porcelain steel sheet is
placed on the glued surface technicians
work carefully to ensure they don't
touch the pressure sensitive surface
with their
fingers then the board moves through the
steel rollers to press the porcelain
steel flat and remove any trapped
air once 50 boards are stacked
technicians put them in a press for half
an hour until the glue
cures
[Music]
in another part of the factory a machine
Cuts material to create the board's
frame it punches v-shaped notches in the
length of aluminum
trim the trim bends at each Notch to
form a wraparound
frame some boards come with a marker
tray that runs along the bottom to make
these trays a technician Cuts board
length pieces from a piece of L-shaped
metal
trim since the tray ends are sharp a
technician attaches plastic covers for
protection he secures the plastic and
covers with screws on both ends of the
[Music]
part meanwhile technicians peel off the
protective film covering the writing
surface then they flip over the board to
assemble the parts from the
back this model doesn't have the
traditional wraparound frame instead it
has a frame comprised of four straight
c-shaped pieces that fit over the
board's
edges to add stability technicians
attach screws through the trim into the
substrate
once assembly is complete the dry erase
board is placed into a box ready to be
shipped to a business or classroom near
you electroic technology mimics the
effect of Ink on paper the screens
reflect light unlike conventional backet
displays that emit light also known as
eaper this technology has changed change
the way we see our
screens mobile devices e-readers smart
watches and credit cards all contain
electr foric displays with its
print-like readability and Bluetooth
capability it's easy to see the
attraction to make an electrooptic
screen polyethylene film is placed on a
sheet of glass which holds the film as
it's
processed
production takes place in a filtered
room to keep the area contaminant free
inside the room robots move the glass
carrier through processes that transform
the film into the back plane the back
plane is the main structure of the
screen it carries the organic
transistors that drive the
electrophoretic
display Machinery builds up micro thin
layers of metal Organic Solutions
semiconductors and
isolators this spin coater evenly
spreads the material across the
film nozzles apply an organic solution
that acts as a booster for the
semiconductors the spin coater closes
and rotates the glass carrier to spread
the deposited material by centrifugal
force the automated system adds layers
of semiconductor
electrical isolators and
metal a rinse of deionized water cleans
the coated film and a blast of air blows
off the water rollers apply gentle
pressure to ensure the film sticks to
the glass even when positioned
[Music]
vertically once the photoresist chemical
has been applied the film goes into an
exposure chamber a pattern mask is
placed in front of the film to block out
Lighting in some
areas the exposure defines the structure
of the metal layers so that when
combined with the other materials
they'll serve as
transistors the back plane film is
removed from the glass carrier now the
film is ready for the electronic ink
sheet placement a technician places the
back plane in a laminator he uses a
camera to magnify and position the back
plane a vacuum in the laminator Chuck
pulls the back plane in
place he places the electronic ink sheet
on the Chuck beside the back
plane and peels off the liner exposing
the
adhesive then the ink sheet and the back
plane are fused
together a roller presses the assembly
for full
[Music]
adhesion once the lamination process is
complete a technician removes the screen
from the
Chuck this is the back plane before and
after the electronic in
[Music]
lamination an automated system bonds the
electronics to a circuit board that's
attached to the display
screen the system mechanically seals the
circuit board polymer resin is applied
for
stability UV light cures the
resin this is the electr 4tic display
before and after the electronics have
been
added this particular display screen
will be an
e-reader they load a graphic with black
strips onto the screen the strips serve
as reference points points as a printer
applies a combination red green and blue
filter the filter adds the option of
colored text or
pictures the primary colors can be
combined to create other Shades
expanding the visual possibilities of
the electronic
ink a machine bends a sample screen
repeatedly to confirm that the sample is
flexible enough to be formed into a
bracelet or credit
card
additional tests are conducted to
confirm that the electr foric display
has the desired Clarity and color
display patterns can be sent from a
phone to a bracelet that has an electr
foric screen with electr foric
technology there are many different ways
to enjoy screen
time